la tormenta tropical fiona en el caribe
ya se convirtió en huracán y está a
punto de llegar a puerto arriba eeuu
declaró el estado de emergencia en el
territorio no incorporado que agiliza
las operaciones de socorro en caso de
desastre tenemos análisis
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
lidera hoy una comisión parlamentaria de
visita en armenia cuyo conflicto con
azerbaiyán revivió esta semana después
de dos años de tregua mientras pelosi
promete apoyo a ereván y bakú la acusa
de desestabilizar la región
y reino unido- últimos detalles para el
funeral de la reina isabel segunda a
londres terminan de llegar los líderes
mundiales para rendir homenaje y asistir
a la ceremonia prevista para este lunes
mientras tanto miles de personas
continúan esperando su turno en filas de
hasta 8 km para darle el último adiós a
la monarca tenemos una foto
bienvenidos a las noticias de fin de
semana en france24 soy daniela blandón
bienvenidos
comenzamos con la poderosa tormenta
fiona en el caribe que se convirtió en
huracán a medida que avanza con
dirección a puerto rico y a república
dominicana ante la inminencia de la
llegada primero a la isla y la amenaza
de inundaciones y deslizamientos que
ponen en peligro a sus habitantes el
presidente de eeuu joe biden aprobó la
declaración de emergencia la decisión
permite proporcionar medidas de
protección en caso de que ocurra un
desastre para profundizar sobre este
tema conectamos en puerto rico con ángel
crespo él es consultor y antiguo jefe
del cuerpo de bomberos y manejo de
emergencias de la isla los saludo muy
buenas tardes para usted los aeropuertos
entonces ya están cerrados que otras
medidas pueden tomar las autoridades
para tratar de minimizar el impacto de
este huracán
saludos daniela ya todos los puertos
marítimos y puertos aéreos han sido
cerrados como bien mencionas es parte de
la cuando se emite un aviso de tormenta
tropical pero hace unas horas se
estableció ya que es un huracán
categoría 1 tiene vientos sostenidos de
80 millas por hora y yo estoy en el área
donde más fuerte se va a sentir porque
estoy en el sur de puerto rico así que
el llamado a la ciudadanía en este
momento definitivamente a mantenerse en
sus hogares
el llamado previo era desalojar áreas
inundables y en este momento pues
estamos recibiendo directamente el
impacto de un huracán categoría 1 señor
crespo que tan preparado está puerto
rico para afrontar un huracán de grandes
magnitudes teniendo en cuenta que
todavía quedan secuelas del desastre que
trajo consigo el huracán maría hace
cinco años y considerado en ese momento
el más letal de la historia de puerto
rico- la electricidad por ejemplo no ha
vuelto a la normalidad
el sistema eléctrico de puerto rico era
una de las cosas más lastimadas que
tiene nuestra infraestructura no solo
por su longevidad si como bien has dicho
por el impacto del huracán maría se ha
asignado un presupuesto grandísimo que
históricamente nunca eeuu había llevado
a cabo un desembolso como ese para la
reparación de lo que conocemos acá como
el crit eléctrico sin embargo pues
todavía todos esos desembolsos toman
mucha planificación siempre hay temas
burocráticos así que es uno de los temas
más importantes unidos a la erosión
costera que precisamente se exacerbó no
solamente por el calentamiento global y
el aumento en el nivel del mar sino por
la marejada ciclónica de maría así que
hay muchas comunidades vulnerables y uno
de los riesgos mayores precisamente son
este tipo de comunidades que están en
zona inundable shahram y bueno y qué
implicaciones tiene entonces esta
declaración de eeuu de emergencia en la
zona que en que cambia eso la situación
es un alivio precisamente para los
gobiernos municipales en puerto rico el
nivel del gobierno más básico el
gobierno municipal y los alcaldes y
alcaldesas son los respondedores de
emergencia así que por lo menos ellos
van a poder hacer una reclamación de los
gastos previos al incidente de los
gastos en la categoría de respuesta a un
programa que se conoce como el programa
de asistencia pública las categorías a y
b cuando se aprueba o se declara estado
de emergencia
van a ser elegibles para reembolso de
ese tipo de gastos
señor crespo muchas gracias por
acompañarnos nosotros entonces cambiamos
de región y seguimos hablando de un tema
similar porque el tifón nanmadol tocó
tierra en japón pese a haberse
debilitado en las últimas horas el
fenómeno mantiene activa la alerta
máxima por fuertes vientos y abundantes
lluvias con el temor de los daños
humanos y materiales también que pueda
causar se trata del tifón número 14 de
esta temporada en pasar por el país
asiático el fenómeno registra de rachas
de viento de hasta 250 kilómetros por
hora las autoridades llaman a tomar
medidas de precaución
además de vientos violentos olas altas y
marejadas ciclónicas se necesitará un
mayor nivel de vigilancia contra
deslizamientos de tierra inundaciones y
desbordes de ríos
que
no se acerquen a zonas peligrosas
eficiente que está en peligro no dude en
evacuar por favor tomen medidas
tempranas para salvar sus vidas y
evacuar de noche es extremadamente
peligroso evacúe áreas seguras como
lugares altos y edificios sólidos
mientras todavía hay luz
al menos un muerto dejó este domingo un
nuevo sismo en taiwán de magnitud de 7.2
según informó la agencia nacional de
bomberos el fenómeno registrado en la
capital taipei se produjo horas después
de los terremotos de magnitud de 6.8 que
tuvieron lugar horas antes este mismo
domingo y en la noche del sábado y que
causaron el colapso de varios edificios
a esta hora se desconoce la escala de
los daños causados
cambiamos de información la presidenta
de la cámara de representantes de eeuu
nancy pelosi condenó durante su visita a
armenia lo que llamó ataques ilegales
por parte de azerbaiyán
peloso y lidera desde el sábado una
comisión parlamentaria considerada como
la visita del político estadounidense de
mayor rango al país desde que obtuvo su
independencia hace 30 años en ereván en
la capital pelosi afirmó que eeuu debe
apoyar a armenia en el conflicto que se
reactivó esta semana después de dos años
de tregua con enfrentamientos que dejan
alrededor de 200 muertos mientras que el
gobierno a seguir rechazó sus
declaraciones y aseguró que no
contribuyen a la paz regional
en nuestra reunión nuevamente tuvo una
importancia particular para nosotros
debido al enfoque de seguridad luego de
los ataques ilegales y mortales de
azerbaiyán en el territorio armenio
condenamos enérgicamente esos ataques
nosotros y nuestra delegación en nombre
del congreso que amenazan las
perspectivas de un muy necesario acuerdo
de paz
y de armenia pasamos a iran en donde
decenas de personas protestaron en
contra la brutalidad policial en el
funeral de massa a mm y la joven que
murió tras ser arrestada por la llamada
policía de la moral la mujer de 22 años
fue detenida por no llevar el 'hiyab'
correctamente activistas por los
derechos humanos acusan a la fuerza
pública de haberla golpeado hasta la
muerte pero las autoridades rechazan
esta versión más detalles en el
siguiente informe
cantos de muerte al dictador mientras el
dolor se convierte en rabia en el
funeral de más ánimo para los dolientes
hay pocas dudas sobre quién mató a la
joven de 22 años acusan a la policía de
la moral de irán de haber golpeado a la
mujer hasta la muerte
una afirmación negada por las
autoridades barbosa hasta ahora no hay
pruebas de que las autoridades le hayan
pegado estamos siguiendo de cerca este
asunto para ver si ha habido algún golpe
técnicamente los policías de la moral no
tienen herramientas para golpear son
tienen porras ni ninguna otra
herramienta en la voz tu mirada naval
servidor a las autoridades tienen una
versión diferente de los hechos
respaldada dicen por esta grabación que
parece haber sido editada más a mí me
fue detenida por no cumplir el estricto
código de vestimenta iraní la policía
afirma que tuvo un problema de salud
mientras esperaba en una comisaría de la
moral con otros detenidos dicen que tuvo
un ataque al corazón pero su familia
niega que sufriera de alguna enfermedad
cardíaca en las imágenes parece que se
desploma mientras habla con otras
personas más tarde murió en él el
presente de gran prometió una
investigación completa sin embargo su
muerte ha vuelto a poner en el punto de
mira a la policía de la moral iraní y
sus estrictas leyes que obligan a las
mujeres a cubrirse el pelo ya llevar
ropa holgada en los últimos meses
activistas de derechos humanos han
instado a las mujeres a quitarse el velo
para desafiar el código de vestimenta
islámico de gran
continuamos este informativo en
reinounido hacia donde están terminando
de llegar los líderes internacionales
invitados al funeral de la reina isabel
segunda que se celebrará mañana en
londres entre ellos el presidente de
eeuu joe biden la presidenta de la
comisión europea a ursula von der leyen
o el rey de españa felipe sexto para los
ciudadanos de a pie las filas para
entrar a la capilla ardiente- pueden
durar hasta 14 horas paralelamente la
capital británica se prepara para el
mayor funeral del estado de las últimas
décadas con dispositivos de seguridad
sin precedentes conectamos por eso con
nuestra corresponsal en londres louis ha
pulido luisa muy buenas tardes
como avanza esta jornada que tan largas
están las filas para ver el féretro de
la reina en este último día
buenas tardes miles y miles de personas
continúan en estas kilométricas filas
como ustedes pueden ver a mis espaldas a
esta hora continúan rindiendo este
tributo personal para ellos que es
aguantar el frío el sol las bajas
temperaturas para poder despedir a su
reina a la reina isabel segunda las
filas por fortuna el tiempo de espera ha
bajado de 14 a 10 horas pero hay tantas
personas en estas filas que el gobierno
ha pedido a la gente que no lleguen ya
al punto de inicio porque seguramente no
van a alcanzar a despedir a la reina
dado que la cámara ardiente estará
abierta
alrededor de 12 horas más luego el ataúd
de isabel segunda hiera será llevado a
la abadía de westminster para este
funeral sin precedentes e histórico como
lo mencionaba aquí en la cámara ardiente
en el westminster hall en el parlamento
que ustedes pueden ver a mis espaldas
han rendido tributos a isabel segunda el
presidente de eeuu joe biden y su esposa
la primera dama de ucrania los reyes de
españa los reyes de bélgica la
presidenta de la comisión europea
también el presiente de francia y otros
dignatarios que asisten a este funeral
rinden un tributo a isabel 2a luisa que
más podemos decir de la llegada de estos
líderes mundiales a londres cuál será su
agenda en las próximas horas
asisten a esta hora a una recepción
ofrecida por el rey carlos tercero en el
palacio de buckingham la cantidad el
número de asistentes de todos los
lugares y rincones del mundo nos
demuestra la influencia que tuvo la
reina isabel en 70 años en el trono y
que tiene aún la corona británica son
alrededor de 500 invitados de 200
territorios y países esto es la
importancia que tiene aún la corona
británica también esta noche él se
rendirá un tributo especial a la reina
isabel un minuto de silencio en todo el
reino unido
a luisa muchas gracias desde londres y
cambiamos ahora de información para
hablar de la guerra en ucrania una
prisión rusa improvisada y una cámara de
tortura esos son los más recientes
hallazgos en la región ucraniana de
jarkiv concretamente en andratx este
distrito está ubicado a unos 140
kilómetros al noroeste de la ciudad de
visión que retomaron las fuerzas de kiev
esta semana y en donde encontraron
decenas de fosas comunes con los cuerpos
de personas muertas supuestamente bajo
la ocupación rusa las tropas ucranianas
hallaron más de 400 cadáveres que están
siendo examinados para determinar las
causas exactas de las defunciones el
alcalde del distrito de dera chih
aseguró que civiles ucranianos fueron
torturados en sótanos
y este fin de semana se celebran en
francia las jornadas europeas del
patrimonio una oportunidad para visitar
lugares de interés cultural que no
suelen estar abiertos al público
ocultos entre los muros de este hospital
parisino documentos históricos que el
público puede ver por primera vez este
hospital especializado en afecciones
oftalmológicas fue inaugurado en el
siglo 13 por el rey luis noveno
de emoción y resulta muy emotivo
encontrar las instrucciones escritas que
dio el rey de risa hace más de 700 años
y que conciernen a un establecimiento
que sigue atendiendo hoy en día a
personas que sufren deficiencias
visuales
en las jornadas del patrimonio de este
año la atención se centra en explorar
los retos a los que se enfrentan estos
lugares de interés en función del cambio
climático este año muchas ciudades
también ponen el foco en mujeres
creadoras en el pasado el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón creó la lotería
del patrimonio hace cinco años a quien
querer un teatro del siglo 19 que lleva
cuatro décadas vacío recibirá 500 mil
euros procedentes de esta iniciativa
desde el 2018 se han salvado 745 lugares
en peligro tanto en francia como en el
extranjero por lo que es una campaña
extraordinaria que ha sido posible
gracias a esta lotería y que enriquece y
da visibilidad a las asociaciones
locales
en el programa se ha insertado además
una mirada entre los bastidores de
notredame para observar las técnicas de
restauración que se utilizan tras el
devastador incendio de 2019
de esta manera finalizamos este resumen
informativo en france 24 recuerda
quedarse conectados con nosotros en
france 24 y en france 24 punto com